nos concurrents d'hier doivent devenir
nos alliés d'aujourd'hui
radio-canada tend la main aux médias
régionaux et leur propose un nouveau
type de collaboration
ce qui est important pour nous ce devoir
avec les entreprises de presse elle-même
le type de collaboration qui serait le
plus approprié selon leur propre réalité
ça peut être est ce qu'on décide de
faire un partenariat dans un marché
également ça peut être de l'inventaire
publicitaire qui est non vendus qu'on
rend disponible pour faire mettre la
promotion des abonnements un journaux ça
peut être certain partage de contenus en
informations la confiance des citoyens
est essentielle
lors de son audition à la commission
radio canada a aussi milité pour une
presse libre et indépendante
le mur de chine entre l'entreprise de
presse et la salle des nouvelles
ça c'est fondamental comment est-ce que
vous pouvez nous garantir qu'ils
reposent six jours nous de plus où vous
êtes à bout de vous critiquez vous
quebecor hier la question de
l'indépendance journalistique amener un
échanges corsés entre la députée de
taschereau et pierre karl péladeau je
viens d'ajouter c'est une vraie question
mais c'est une vraie réponse que je vous
donne aujourd'hui certains
s'inquiétaient d'une trop grande
concentration de la presse la volonté du
propriétaire et gestionnaire percolé
jusqu'à la salle de rédaction par
l'intermédiaire des cas c'est ce que la
recherche nous nous dit donc un malaise
lié à ce disque un rempart contre son
ouïe un rapport en fait ce sont les
règles déontologiques c'est aussi je
pense l'attitude d'indépendance que
doivent afficher tous les journalistes
tout les journalistes indépendance à
l'égard de leurs patrons indépendance à
l'égard des lobbys la commission sur
l'avenir des médias fera un rapport sur
ses travaux et la concentration de la
presse sera nécessairement abordés
évidemment qu'on doit demeurer préoccupé
sur la concentration de la presse parce
que c'est hydrequent te ment la
diversité de l'information
une autre question a été abordée en
commission celle de la distribution des
imprimés décès transcontinental qui
distribuent de nombreux hebdos régionaux
avec son publisac a défendu ce modèle
d'affaires et la fin du publisac serait
la fin des hebdos nous recommandons donc
que la commission reconnaisse le rôle
primordial que joue le publisac pour
assurer aux abdos la portée et
l'efficacité dont ils ont besoin à des
coûts qui leur permettront de continuer
d'exister
une dernière journée d'audition aura
lieu vendredi à l'assemblée nationale et
par la suite
commissaire se rendront dans le bas
saint laurent et en abitibi
témiscamingue pour des sessions
informelles de travail
le rapport de la commission est attendue
au cours des prochains mois ici louis
philippe ouimet radio canada québec